yeah hello and welcome to this video
after many months actually of work it's
ready and it is released today my new
opening course fight like Magnus the
Sicilian yeah I'm happy to show you a
little bit of the course
um not many lines actually I'm showing
you a quick outline because we this time
have a pretty large preview video
available that is linked in the
description below and I'm going to show
you this short yeah we have a page for
this that me
go over there quite quickly so we have
this free lesson it's um
two hours I think two hours and a couple
of minutes two hours ten or so total um
I'm where I basically go through the
whole repertoire the whole Sicilian
repertoire and the link is in the
description below so um for former
courses ahead I was delayed a leap
reviewers of ten minutes just showing
the start the beginnings of the videos
we're not going to do this anymore for
this time we have a full to our preview
video so okay going back you to this I'm
going to brief you show you what this is
all about so we have a Sicilian
repertoire for black and it's basically
using Magnus's games as the blueprint
yeah as the UM as the model to go form
so I have checked all his games and he
has played the Sicilian um almost
exclusively in the last year but also in
his younger years quite a lot and
there's actually plenty of material to
to go to go with so the backbone of the
repertoire is the slash knockoff
variation starting with E five this is
known as one of the sharper lines in the
Sicilian for sure the Sicilian generally
is quite sharp but this is known as a
more aggressive line but in fact I think
compared to many other Sicilian
variations is actually not that
difficult to learn like except some
structural problems with the weak spot
on d5 sometimes the pawn but rarely a
relevant factor more the the square on
d5 can be a strategic problem but we
have many young active and dynamic
possibilities in this position often
based on the fact that white loses a lot
of time with his knights and we get off
in a powerful counter play later on the
kingside again I don't want to really
show you all kinds of variations we have
this really extensive previa video out
where you can check out the whole
repertoire I'm basically showing you
a little bit of everything so you would
even with the preview video already know
quite a bit about the Sicilian um I have
not only included the main lines here
and especially cough but also all the
lines that could happen as side lines
they often played actually on the club
level or in youth tournaments yeah you
see moves like Knight c3 for example or
c3 very very frequently if you are not
on the world championship level and I
have fun he I used Magnus's replies
there to find good anti towards against
them I've also of course examined
Alliance like the Rosso lemo which is
popular on all levels basically bomb
Knight c3 which is a popular anti
national offline used on the top level
quite a bit and for all those sidelines
I have um yeah still while using
Magnus's games I have chosen setups that
are somewhat similar to one another that
share strategic themes for example here
I recommend be 5 or the so-called would
Vinick set up in line that um Magnus has
played successfully quite a bit and
similar structures are reached against
lines like d3 for example or against
many of the closed lines where right for
example goes here which we go g6 and
later a 5 year as well so there's a
common strategic even there for all the
side lines
yeah I think the Sicilian with its non
symmetrical nature is a very attractive
opening or players of all levels
actually and I'm very happy to present
this repertoire to you I think it would
be good fun to play and yeah leads to
exciting games more often than not I
myself have played the sveshnikov quite
a bit some years ago but yeah as it is
I'm always getting eager to explore new
stuff and now I will probably return to
it again
I have tried already in games but people
play it enters the zillions against me
yeah two terms but it will happen that I
get a full loans
again on the board so make sure to check
out our preview page I'm going to go on
this again our preview page when you can
get a free lesson here basically a full
at the end more than two hour video of
this course it's some untestable and
it's on sale for a couple of days so if
you are interested go there and get it
alright thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed this little preview of my new
course bye bye